Hey look at this yeah this John you see
this
I've passed John it looks like we we
have the same we have the same score
anti brakes so I don't know why I'm
slightly ahead maybe based on raining
but John and John still tied for first
nine players with three points
look up look at some games I can't
finish
ooh this game oh wait was just in time
there it blocks winning that game let's
look at this game this looks kind of
cool iods versus DZ one two three
a very strange bone structure like white
white spawns are impressive with Sora
black spawns but wait spawns are smiling
ooh
but now their spots of smiles just
destroyed ouch box up now four pawns and
resins tough finish yeah before white
lost all the pawns it looked interesting
why Crowley should have somehow kept
Queens on the board but there's a
there's a pin anyway mmm where's you
John John's number eleven so it's
possible that John will play like a two
and a half pointer I'm still trying to
figure out this pairing system it would
be nice if they shared their pairings
like they could share their pairings
right now
but okay we'll find out in about five
seconds yeah be cool like if you knew
the pairings right like with more time
and if there were like five five minute
breaks then there'd be time to prepare
okay so I'm playing someone who's also
won all three games and we're having
another Java London maybe everyone
playing Joe Bava London so I played this
in round 2 against a 1200 1200 played
remarkably well okay my opponent
thinking here that's a nice sign
a black lion not this game sticking with
the anti Java London this is a Sam
Jenkins recommendation v6 but should be
45 ideas probably Queen a5 develop
though
yeah 92 kind of neutralizes
considering this move looks kind of
fancy I'm just curious what weights
going to do against this
I'm trying to pressure both sides trying
to basically make this night over works
yeah slow flight takes here okay it
doesn't happen so I'll take here about
25 John
John are you playing a game are you
thinking game and gifting sons things
John gifting a sub to Lord ninja 34 not
sure what my Knights should be doing
like b6 Bishop a6
a c4 might happen play b6 it's really
the clear clear home for the bishop
I mean really well I just want to do is
complete development on the Queen side
and use the C file because these pawns
could be long term weaknesses
[Music]
I'll try and answer questions between
games and not during games the last game
I played made me realize that I can't
rely on I'm talking on dirty flagging
like I really just have to focus on
trying to play good moves in whites
position actually looks very reasonable
you're like a nice Center and my King is
still on castled I probably have to take
and then in castle and d5 coming
[Music]
might get away with taking first not
sure let's try it
I'm thinking at first Queen takes with
them the e5 so we have one of these
positions where White has a center in
space but so many minor pieces are
traded off that I'm not really cramped
at all and the center could come under
fire with the rooks entering the game
my rook probably the queenside rook
wants to be here the rook this rook
might stay on on f8 for a bit just to
cover up seven Iraq f3 slightly scary
but not too scary
let's see choose weak c3 good move
maybe e5u 595 - six - 85 95 let's try it
thanks for subbing malice of forethought
for four months appreciate that
there's also 94 year
I'm 94 kind of winds upon the might run
into trouble
o to do
as a scary position
[Music]
she don't know what to do here
I was much more scared of not each five
this is still scary though
if f5 if antis I when the Queen its whoa
white wondered the Queen it's one of
these unusual situations where both
pawns vanish from the the rink
okay let's say this rook take a pawn
afterwards I'll show a slow-motion
replay yeah I've seen this happen a few
times
well yeah it's it's one of these weird
cases in chess we're both pawns vanish
so this pawn was basically pinned to the
Queen even though there's a pawn on f5
now that might be YouTube worthy just
for it's just for that finish finish cuz
it looks so natural to like take an
attack but I was happy with that five
has it keeps everything safe like rook
g3 rack f7 Queenie 7 also revin was much
more scared of knowledge 5 here I might
just be losing after 9 H 5 yeah and with
that you to people say hi to tog II and
I'll see you in the future